respect the [ __ ] you've got some of the
hottest actors in the world in this
movie let's start with Tom Cruise okay
how'd you get him he called me after
he'd seen Boogie Nights and that's the
phone call from the president of the
United States of the movie land you know
and
tame the [ __ ] but he called me he was a
big fan of Boogie Nights and so I was
going to London to promote uh to promote
it and I met at my minimum instead of
eyes wide shot and
visited with them and I got to meet
Stanley Kubrick and so Tom and I just
sort of chatted and I was just starting
to think of this character that he plays
in the movie and so I wrote wrote Frank
TJ Mackey the part for Tom and he and
sent it to him eight or nine months
later you know I said let me go away I'm
gonna write I'll send you that I didn't
tell him anything about it I said let me
go write this thing and I'll send it
send it to you and so you know many
months later when he was finally
finishing up eyes wide shot many many
years later yeah
[Applause]
[Music]